you what to play questions let's play
that you have to ask questions statement
one love unreal
I'm real
[Music]
I think the average stormtrooper does
not install a toilet main holes they
know is killing in white uniforms yeah
if you could just go ahead and make sure
you do that from now on that would be
great
[Music]
second time the light is much better on
the hands
you pop back to Janet once the call is
already moving private photos if great
power comes great responsibility
this is my gift my curse
[Music]
ever thought about my responsibilities
it's not personal
strictly business I want to know
tell me
fan Danko not fan oh no Sam
hey buddy I'm not paying you to heal
your thoughts on life I'm paying you to
sing
[Music]
[Music]
I am an FBI agent
[Music]
took that from me I stole that from me
Jill that from me people keep asking if
I'm back and I haven't really had an
answer but now yeah I'm taking on back
[Music]
well you know that's just like your
opinion man 60% of the time it works
every time
[Music]
[Music]
so you think chocolate is the end-all
and Beall of ice-cream deal it's the
best ice cream I wouldn't order any of
them oh so it's all chocolatey with it
yes chocolate is all I need
well I need more than chocolate for that
matter I need more than vanilla I
believe that we need freedom the choice
when it comes for ice cream and that joy
nailer that is the definition of Liberty
I wish none of this had happened so do
all who live to see such times but that
is not for them to decide all we have to
decide is what to do with the time of
this given to us hope is a good thing
maybe the best of things and no good
thing ever Joy's you've got to keep
living man Li VI n I love you I'm not
even embarrassed to say I just I I love
you Chloe I think this is the beginning
of a beautiful friendship
[Music]